je vais jouer ben hamad al thani qui
joue jurent ils s'entraînent le gars
s'ils pouvaient faire autant de progrès
dans l'émission je suis l'enfant d'une
route non mais je touche un truc non non
non c'est normal mais je vais répondre
et 1,5 point
si on combine pour un poids de 5 5
points attention si je gagne je prends
tout ouais essai pour le pays et c'est
pour une personne est toujours au
téléphone
ok ils seront heureuses et pourra
s'amuser dès demain dès le 9 mai et chez
vas-y et des voyages bateau semblait pas
non plus
non
il revient dès ce soir dans trois mois
le fait capital
sept vies avec 87 donc là c'est bien sûr
c'est rapide je vais faire les comptes 5
ouais tu as pas
25 toi tu fais mal à la tête je sais que
tu a misé sur benjamin la pie x 65 67 72
non eh oui ici les 76 86 à temps et il
ya de la joie et dans ce cas c'est le
droit 16,87 euros 96 b sur deux et 2 100
101 101 je fais sont un plus un chien
dalmatiens
[Applaudissements]
j'essaie en cinq points si je gagne je
prends les cymbales et je les offre à
quelqu'un et bien sûr cette personne il
gagne pourra utiliser je gagne si vous
gagnez joffre c'est ici ces cinquante
six pour accepter dé 50 balles je te dis
que dans ses poésies mai et tu puis
quand tu fais les règles mais j'aime
excusez-moi chef 50 balles 50 ballons
d'ibahn bon toi c'est 400 balles ont
tout autant te dire vous dire chez vous
que si benjamin castaldi guen on perd le
chauffeur de sang vous avez bien je suis
maman katie cassidy gagne il y à poste à
pourvoir la lenteur de vous l'avez
compris la south beach près bah je suis
presque sûr d'argent tu le vends
distributeurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et c'est bien là tout le temps à damas
qui est extrêmement fort et soit bon les
chéris je rappelle je rappelle le
hashtag castaldi est une banane on
prendre à quelqu'un au téléphone acheté
castaldi est une banane attention c'est
un 5-3 aux tirs pour elle et ses amies
on voulait que je sers allez-y je vous
en prie ce n'est pas un cadeau
enlève tout aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'onu
il était parti très très vite aussi dans
sa carrière
[Applaudissements]
mais attention il faut choisir en place
avant de serrer a tant fait descendre tu
perds ton slip on veut tuer des
attentions
[Applaudissements]
mentalement il est très fort là tu as eu
des broches et des broches et en
prétendant être toi tu as eu un truc
bien mais quoi qu'on en dise mes excuse
moi tu crois qu'on va faire pendant huit
heures qu'est ce qu'elle a dit est ce
que soient l'âge et l'autre à aa
sans déconner quand même c'est tout
simple 5
non mais ça va alors je veux dire c'est
trop court 5e sais pas ce que dit sa
femme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu joue vachement bien et de chaque
meilleur
[Musique]
tous les cours à bamba concentrant te
déstabiliser ce fait l'ambiance à la wau
dix mois ce qu'il te faut rien du tout
130 watts angie tu vas lui mais bon tout
prix mais si vous nous rejoignez sachez
que toute l'équipe a misé de l'argent
benjamin castaldi joue à 10 contre 1 si
benjamin castaldi rsa diégane je paye
tout le monde dix foix est là qui ont
mis 5 euros 10 euros il y en a un il
s'est complètement voyant mais il a vu
son salaire ne gagne partir en cacahuète
total
eric le fait de moins en moins
d'ambiance à terme arrêts alors je le
dis ratant quelques instants sur un
chauffeur de salle dépressive
par contre toi t'es vachement bien
enceinte et ouais je me demande si
l'année prochaine je vais pas te mettre
en å uvre de mort sachant que les jeux
d'argent sur internet elle était moins
bien que ses bons jours
ouais tu sors de sang
[Applaudissements]
pas possible et on aura moins de
problèmes sans lui les prochaines tu
vois toi tu joues bien et un souci
annoncé que tu paniques
c'est pour ça que tu dis voir souvent
respire bien beau mais si vous n'avez
pas de mental castaldi plague et tous
possible c'est bien seulement ils feront
chacun des quatre points alors
franchement j'ai trois balles gagnées et
perdues la chine moi tu tues ça m'amuse
beaucoup votre truc là nouveau début ça
nous amuse et là on a envie de spectacle
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya 4 1 qu'est ce tu veux faire
je propose deux points de plus ces trois
pôles imbriquent je vais prendre mon
iphone je sais de marquer le dernier
point l'iphone est ok t'as pas un gros
le groupe sino françaises benhaim ouais
bah non t'es gentil à quoi ce serait la
fin du match non non non ça se change
qu'on joue et est pourquoi faveur et le
gallon mais toi tu sais c'est pas
possible ça hein et vas-y aléas de son
genou ne joue pas mieux avec ça
non bah ouais enfin bon
bravo à vos valises un bébé ça va le
faire
non
[Applaudissements]
non merci
mais chut
ces messieurs merci des chiens merci
merci merci merci merci